now to San Francisco where there is
growing outrage over the death of a man
killed while allegedly shoplifting from
a Walgreens surveillance video shows
Banco Brown struggling with a security
guard before he was shot and killed
Brown was unarmed the D.A says no
charges will be brought against the
guard Nancy Chan has more and we do want
to warn you the video is difficult to
watch
for protests continued in San Francisco
following the release of surveillance
video by the District Attorney's Office
showing the moment's 24 year old Banco
Brown was shot and killed that will be
bringing a complaint a civil action
complaint against Walgreens and security
company and the eight and the security
officer himself famed civil rights
attorney John Burris is representing
Brown's family and says the shooting was
unnecessary and unlawful I'm surprised
that the district attorney after seeing
that video chose not to go forward
surveillance footage shows brown with a
bag in his hand walking toward the exit
the security guard Michael Earl Wayne
Anthony blocks Brown pushing and shoving
him the guard then appears to punch
Brown several times before knocking him
down to the ground the men continue
fighting for several seconds until Brown
grabs the bag and heads to the exit he
turns toward Anthony who then fires a
single shot at Brown who died later at
the hospital Burris says the video shows
Anthony as the clear aggressor security
officer wasn't being beat up the
security officer was really physically
punching on him tossing him around like
he was a rag muffin but during an
interview with police Anthony says Brown
threatened to stab him with a knife the
whole time we were wrestling
she was saying that she was going to
stab me
and that's what really put the fear in
my heart San Francisco district attorney
Brooke Jenkins said it was that
interview the video that in part fueled
her decision not to pursue murder
charges because Anthony instead acted in
self-defense we have to believe at the
time that we charge a case that a jury
of 12 would convict not let's just
charge the case and see what happens
both Walgreens and the security company
Anthony worked for have issued
statements expressing condolences to
Brown's family Brown who is transgender
was known for helping black transgender
Youth and had been struggling with
homelessness and the weeks before his
death tapes are just telling us
everything we know that Branco was
murdered because of his crime of being
hungry
so many questions in that story when you
look at the video it for me it's hard to
see exactly what's going on but because
there was a there was clearly some kind
of struggle there yeah he says he was
afraid of his life that he had been
threatened but it just seems like there
was another way that could have ended
yeah that's the best person was unarmed
yeah and leaving and leaving the store
well yeah very upset shoplifting is a
big issue in San Francisco a lot of big
cities I don't I don't know what the
boundaries of appropriate reaction are
for security guards
all right that was Nancy Chen reporting